this village is home to innocent bonda
and his family
the 29 year old volunteer teacher is
getting ready to head to work
in germany teachers struggle with how to
teach students best
but here innocent has to fight just to
keep girls in class
this morning he's heading to work
earlier than normal
he wants to visit the families of
several girls who haven't been to class
recently
foreign
innocent has heard excuses like these
before
there are many hurdles standing in the
way of zambian children's access to
education
things like poverty parental illiteracy
and most importantly the long way to
school
but innocent refuses to give up on these
children and so he makes his way to the
home of another one of his students
foreign
getting an education is especially hard
for girls they're far more likely to
drop out of school
child marriage and teenage pregnancy
prevent many girls from finishing school
what i want is
you know children are
the future
yeah if those children cannot learn now
as we are getting odds who is going to
occupy to be the tic of commerce who is
going to be the teacher committed if we
can't educate those young ones
there'll be no one that is why i'm
fighting hard
as a volunteer teacher innocent doesn't
see a penny from the government or the
local community sometimes he'll get a
bag of potatoes from a parent
innocent never received any formal
higher education and he's largely
self-taught but that hasn't stopped him
from teaching 289 students here at
kamatiti community school
hello hello
how are you i'm fine and
full-time teacher
in innocence first grade class math is
on today's lesson plan
i'm impressed by the passion that
innocent injects into his lessons
it seems nothing can stop him from
showing his students how education can
improve their lives
although he's working in rough
conditions his smile never fades
and there's a reason to smile
one two three four five six seven eight
nine 10 11 12 13
14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21
23 24 25 26
for the first time there are an equal
number of boys and girls in innocence
first grade class
how are you
one thing i notice is that there are far
fewer students than in first grade
only 14 boys and just four girls have
made the trek to class
most of the students are around 15 years
old
at this age many parents choose to keep
their daughters at home to help around
the house
how do we find the difference between
852
uh by 648
okay
two minus eight
what is two minus eight
like many zambians growing up here
innocent saw the same issues in his own
family
my sister who stopped in grady seven
when my father was still alive
then he
my father could force that child
until she understood that i think i
should go back to school so of that
history in my mind that
if i can force these girls to school one
day they will remember me to say mr
banda innocent was trying to force me to
go to school can you see what am i doing
now who i am
they would be proud of that
really
at noon his seventh grade students are
already done for the day but there's no
time for a break
innocent is busy preparing for his next
class so they appreciate to say oh it's
good what could be done by the
government to improve the school
situation in zambia
um
i would appreciate if the government
could continue uh sensitizing the
community schools if they have programs
they need to invite us so that we should
also know what is going on in zambia in
order for education to be improved then
um they should also include parents
because parents are the ones who are
keeping these children in their homes
after seeing how much passion innocent
puts into his work i wonder why the
government isn't supporting him
we cross the south luangawa national
park on our way to zambia's capital
lusaka
zambia is rich in nature but there are
fewer tourists here than in other
african countries
most people in zambia have to get by on
about a dollar a day
life expectancy here is one of the
lowest in the world
with conditions like these it's no
wonder that education takes a back seat
i want to know more about what the
government is doing to support rural
schools
i have an appointment with lancelat
mutale an official at the ministry of
education
is there already something happening to
improve the situation for teachers in
community schools i would have loved a
situation where in fact
they are given more money
than they are getting now because you're
looking at issues of motivation as well
if you don't pay teachers good money
then it means you are killing the
education system 25 years ago we did not
have this problem of teachers who were
teaching without any pay and the reason
is simple we didn't have such schools
and that also implied that we had more
children who are not going to school
but now we have a scenario where
people were asking questions what are we
doing with this army of uneducated
children they will soon grow up and this
is a potential time bomb yeah actually
it's a good system it's in a kind it's a
good system but i think you have to put
in more structure
more resources and
it's not yet
we solved the problem of illiteracy yeah
so many children growing illiterate yeah
i can call it let me qualify that yeah
we solved the problem of illiteracy so
that now we have more and more children
who can read and write because of the
establishment of such schools but in the
process of solving this problem we have
created another problem of quality so we
were asking which which is a lesser evil
which one is a lesser evil not to have a
good percentage of children in school at
all so that the few that we have can
read very well and and write very well
or to allow as many children to at least
be able to read and write so that when
they go for example to the hospital they
can read the prescription given you know
what we call functional literacy yeah
that is why we're saying because of
trying to expand on
it's four o'clock at the kama tt
community school an innocent is heading
home most afternoons he works the land
picking cotton for the weekly market
he uses the money he earns to send his
own four children to school
he also grows food to feed his family
he's been working for 13 hours
i sometimes become sad because he
have not reached my goal what i want is
to reach to the college so that i
have to educate my children when i'm sad
i used to take a bible
i used to sit in my room
if my family had seen me that i'm sad
then i called my family we sit together
we read the bible we asked god just to
help us to continue doing what we are
doing
muma
innocent has chosen a job that won't
improve his quality of life
but for me at least his selfless
dedication is what teaching is all about